for me and there was no hesitation
because while music and art and museums
not all that in which my life books are
my life and of course I cannot pick one
book and nobody can but but like these
these lists of picking ten out of
millions give you also the possibility
to mention the ones you did not pick
that's why you do this list and and
because on the bottom of it what I would
like to convey to a young person is not
a book but the love of books but but I I
followed a follow and of course there's
a question why books and there are many
answers 1 if the books are agents of
empathy so if you have wandered through
the night Woods is junior Barnes if you
have suffered with push in sapphires
with pressures is her name is also a
movie that we've suffered with precious
and sapphires novel push or if you've
been sad with um tsurumi and banana
yoshimoto novel Amrita which is so
beautiful it's very hard to UM be a
racist afterwards or to be a sexist so
it's compassion and it's understanding
and it is this feeling of unity and
difference of morals and Miss chief and
of triumphant trauma books are witnesses
and agents of witnesses and perpetuators
perpetuators are of what we call the
human nature which is for paradox kind
and problematic and at the same time
astonishingly beautiful but but as a
bottom of it there's only one life
there's only one's life there's only
everybody's one life and this is why I
would choose a philosophical
I will not talk about the books I did
not mention I get it out right away I'd
choose Senecas life is short life is
short is the letter sanika like about
2,000 years ago has written to his
friend Polly knows about the importance
of taking care of one's own soul and the
importance of of leaving one's own life
it's very beautiful very simple and very
deep and it reminds us what it means to
be human that is to be alive and
responsible what means to respond to
that life nothin so sorry I guess book
challenge his ass over the abyss of time
to answer with our own life so then I
got the second question so what would
you do know teach to teach the
younglings yeah and of course I forgot
the most important thing in my essay um
because I think reflection and
correction often go hand in hand and I
forgot to tell what I'm the first thing
I would say to a young person would be I
would encourage him or her encouragement
I will tell my students that every one
of them has everything they need to make
their own life and that they are smart
and they really would like to hear their
thoughts and you know what I really do
this I do this with my students and it
really works and they think for
themselves and sometimes they even
object to me that's what you get that
yeah so seriously whatever teach them
first would be the pav rocks nature of
the human animal like this um strange
coexistence of freedom and dependence of
good and evil off of um greatness and
stupidity or uselessness you know it's
not the same and in in one oneself
and in all ourselves and in the society
and in Norse PCs and so so to understand
that we're not torn but it's a risk
italian-based logic of either or but we
create creatures of as well as as in
beauty as well as suffering and he by we
totally avoid any form of dogmatism like
I'd one who said the whole is the untrue
and my dad you always have a little room
for dissent so I would not encourage
them to be themselves I would encourage
them to be there many cells and then I
would tell them that all good things
take time I let you if you want to
really be good at something have to
strive and to struggle so hard your
balls bleed and then I will tell
them they would fail and then get up
again and then fail again and let get up
again I like another story perseverance
perseverance perseverance and a sense of
humor because humor is the ability to
take everything very serious and
everything very not serious at the same
time and Boyd you really have to know
yourself to laugh at yourself and so I
think this paradox strategy is the best
answer to this wicked wonder we called
life thank you thank you
you